Christian
[Music]
hello hello good to see your
faces um my name's Rachel my pronouns
are she and her so good to see you um
first announcement is if you're
interested in being baptized we're
offering a baptism class immediately
after this service and there's also one
on January 5th they're really short
they're like 20 to 30 minutes long um
and baptisms will be on January 12th
next for Christmas Eve because of some
scheduling challenges our Christmas Eve
service will be next Sunday December
22nd um it's familyfriendly kids are
encouraged to hang out with us we'll
sing Christmas carols light candles all
the things um and there will be a
nursery available for the it ity ones um
now looking at these candles we are
reminded of the presence of Christ Among
Us fully Divine and fully
human now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and productivity and enter the
kingdom of Silence Stillness and
simplicity a Sacred Space a place for
prayer worship and adoration a place to
behold Christ revelation of God and
heartbeat of
creation allow The unforced rhythms of
Grace to find you to mend your heart may
we all come
home thanks Rachel well guys if you want
to stand with us we are going to get
started with some worship I know we had
a couple people bail very last minute
with sickness from our team and I have
kids at home sick and looks like there's
probably a lot of other sickness going
on tonight so you guys are the strong
you have overcome but um that verse what
on my way here I had my little bible app
playing um in the background and there's
that verse that says my peace I leave
with you myace peace I give you I do not
give as the world gives and that has
just been an encouragement to me as We
Gather tonight in the craziness of the
Season where sickness is hitting and
holiday craziness and all the school
events if you have kids all the holiday
exchanges and IND of year parties and it
can just get a little crazy but his
piece is here tonight and we are going
to celebrate that piece together so um
Gary's going to get get us started with
Joy to the World we're going to do a
little bit of a different rendition so
you guys join in and sing and let's um
enjoy the space where we get to make
music and um lift our voices as
one to the world the lord is come let
Earth receive her
King let every heart prepare him room
and heaven and nature sing and heaven
and nature sing and heaven heaven and
nature
sing Joy to the Earth the Savior Reigns
let all their songs
[Music]
by fields and fls Rock Hills and ples
repeat the sounding Joy repeat the
sounding Joy repeat repeat the sounding
Joy I'm going to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder you're going to
hear my Praises Roar up the ashes hope
will
arise death is defeated the king is
[Music]
a he rules the world with truth and gra
and makes the Nations
true the glories of his
rightousness and wonders of his love and
wonders of his love and wers wonders of
his
[Music]
love let every heart prepare him room
and heaven and nature sing and heaven
and nature sing and heaven and heav and
nature sing little
louder Jo to the world sing a little
louder join to the world sing a little
louder and Heaven JY sing a little
louder Joy to the World Sing a little
louder
Heaven JY sing a little
[Music]
louder to sing in the middle of the
storm louder and louder you going to
hear my Praises
Ro From the Ashes hope will
arise death is
defeated the king is
alive I'm all to sing in the middle of
the
storm louder and louder going to hear my
Praises Ro Up From the Ashes hope will
arise death is defeated the king is
[Music]
alive all right kiddos you guys can make
your way to your classes give your
teachers big hugs and thank you tonight
let them know how much we appreciate
them and we are going to move into the
prayers of the
people so if you guys will follow along
on the screens with us and read the
parts in red
aloud Jesus for this city of saxi Texas
and for every city and community and all
who live in them we pray to you for the
Good Earth you have given us and the
wisdom and the will to conserve it we
pray to you for the old and the sick for
the Widow and orphan for the injured and
suffering we pray to you for the poor
and the oppressed the unemployed and
destitute for prisoners and captives and
all who remember and care for them we
pray to you for the vulnerable the
marginalized and those unjustly targeted
for their gender sexuality race or other
perceived difference we pray to you for
the vulnerable the marginalized I'm so
sorry for those experiencing loss
loneliness and disconnection and for
those struggling with mental and
emotional health we pray to you Lord we
know that you love us and that you hear
us and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
[Music]
Scott for the names and the moments that
we have spoken aloud and for those that
we have kept in our hearts we pray to
you that they may have life and Light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
[Music]
amen God I to
you I won be
overwhel
[Music]
me to
see give
me you know what to do
[Music]
God I
youon
beel do God I look to
you you're where my help comes from
give me
[Music]
wi you know what to do and I will love
you Lord my
strength and I will love you Lord
my I will love you Lord my
oh
my I will love you
[Music]
God I you I won't be
over give me
[Music]
vision to see things like you do God I
to
you you my
help
me you know what to do and I will love
you Lord my
sh I will love you Lord my
I Love You Lord
my all my days I will love you
God
hallelu our
hallelujah our god
hallelu
God forever all my days
[Music]
hallelujah I will love you Lord my
strength I will love you Lord my
[Music]
I will love
you
Myck forever all my days I will love you
God oh my days I will love you
Psalm 121 says I lift my eyes up to the
hills where does my help come from my
help comes from the Lord the maker of
heaven and Earth he will not let your
foot slip He Who Watches Over you will
not
Slumber the Lord will keep you from all
harm he will watch over your life the
Lord will watch over your coming and
going both now and for forever
[Music]
more sing
worthy worthy of every song we could
ever
sing worthy of all the praise we could
evering worthy of every breath we could
ever breae we live for
you Jesus the name above every other
name
Jesus the only one who could
ever worthy of every breath we could
ever Brea we live for
you we live for
you and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and fill
me with your heart and Lead Me In Your
Love To
those me
[Music]
wory of every song we could ever
sing worthy of every praise we could
ever
[Music]
bring worthy of every breath we could
ever we live for
you we live for you
Jesus Jesus The Only Name you could ever
say Jesus the only one who could
[Music]
ever worthy of every breath we could
ever bre we live for
you we live for you
oh and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and F me
with your heart and Me in Your Love to
those around me and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside you open up my eyes in
Wonder and show me who you are and F me
keep your heart and Lead Me In Your Love
to
those around me
[Music]
I will build my life
upon your love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone and I will not be
Shen and I will build my life upon your
love it is a firm
foundation and I will put my trust in
you
alone and I will not be
Shen and I will build my
life upon your love it is a firm
found and I will put my trust in in you
alone and I will not be
Shen and
holy there is no one like you there is
none beside
you up my
eyes wonder and show me who you are and
F
with your heart
and in love
[Music]
to God yes I pray that you would lead
us that you would guide us forward
through whatever
comes regardless of the circumstances
the troubles the heartache and the pain
that we are sure to
face even in this season of
Celebration we also remember that it's a
season of
[Music]
waiting and God we wait
today for you to show up in the areas
where we need you most we wait for your
hope knowing that it will not
disappoint we wait for your
light to come Pierce through our
Darkness God help us to hold out in the
waiting help us not to lose
faith help us to stay the
course knowing that our help comes from
the Lord the maker of heaven and
Earth and you will watch over over
us you do bring your son you do come and
meet us
here you are the god with
us so we hold on to that
tonight and throughout this season
God thank you for that love it's in
Jesus name we pray
amen all right you guys say hello to the
people around you and then we'll keep
going
well Grace and peace so good to be with
you all uh yeah really really grateful
and um I want to welcome those join us
online love you all Lots you're not
forgotten uh don't forget to get your
communion stuff for later and um yeah
just really really good to to be with
you and welcome you uh into this this
space I um I also want to give before I
move on a quick little shout out and a
thank you um to gwy gwindel Lao for
preaching last week she did so good I
really I've gotten like a lot of
feedback from people of just like y'all
y'all really enjoyed her and uh she is a
gifted gifted um not only just a gift to
communicator but a like the I don't know
the spirit really moves through her you
know it's more than just a personality
there's a genuine love of God there
that's just comes through and it's it's
awesome so if you missed it you can go
back um on uh the Facebook and catch
that uh it was really yeah good good
message so um oh and also next week um
just a reminder again um of the
Christmas service and I specifically
want to in encourage you to um invite a
friend or someone who could maybe like
hasn't been to church in a while or
maybe isn't really involved in you know
Christian faith or religion really at
all and and uh this you know this kind
of service can be a really um a good
like kind of a bridge for folks you know
who um might not otherwise ever really
darken the door but they're like okay
it's Christmas sure and and you never
know like what that you know turns into
so I encourage you to kind of just
listen to Spirit and see if don't if
there's like a nudge to you know send a
text or something to someone um so
that'll be yeah next week um so we um
are oh and I'm realizing I'm 40 years
old and I forgot my little light oh I
need I'm going to need that um if it is
around and it's not there all right I'll
wing it it'll be fun no I mean I can
still read it kind of I'll just have to
I'll probably like bring this up high
like all right so um yeah I can I can
follow along um so the uh okay so we're
in the season of Advent um which for
those unfamiliar this the Advent comes
from the Latin adventus uh which means
arrival so Advent it's not not exactly
the celebration of Christmas it's it's
more like the season of preparation
Before Christmas um in the same way lint
kind of comes before Easter that that
time of kind of heart and mind uh
preparation so that's that's kind of the
Season we're in so it's actually been
kind of in church history actually like
a season of fasting and prayer and
things like that um so uh yes that's
kind of the the vibe and you'll be able
to tell in the readings the one I did
two weeks ago uh the one tonight like
it's it's different you know it's not
not like he is born you know or the
Angels proclaimed or it's like none of
that um and that's why because it's the
kind of preparing before um before
Christ is born so our uh so the title of
the message tonight is feel the burn and
uh our reading is Luke Chapter 3: 7-18
it's a a text from the prophet John the
Baptist um whose Ministry kicked off
right before Jesus so if you like follow
along in the script kind of the readings
that are assigned for each week
um during Advent they're like John the
Baptist features very prominently uh
because it's it's sort of the perfect
season for his readings right because
he's like preparing the way for Christ
you know so you get a lot in Advent a
lot of John the Baptist kind of prepare
you know our hearts and Minds for for
Christ and such so uh with that in mind
so this is Luke 3 starting in verse 7
John said to the crowds coming out to be
baptized by him you brood of vipers
who warned you to flee from the coming
wrath produce fruit in keeping with
repentance and do not begin to say to
yourselves oh we have Abraham as our
father I tell you that out of these
Stones God can raise up children for
Abraham the axe is already at the root
of the trees and every tree that does
not produce good fruit will be cut down
and thrown into the fire what should we
do then the crowd asked John answered
anyone who has two shirts should share
with the one who has none anyone who has
food should do the same even Tax
Collectors came to be baptized teacher
they asked what should we do don't
collect any more than you're required to
he told them and some soldiers asked him
what should we do he replied don't
extort
money uh don't accuse people falsely be
content with your pay you can see there
with both tax collectors and Roman
soldiers um that this was these are
positions especially in the ancient
world even today but especially in the
ancient world that lend themselves to
corruption right you have a certain
amount of power over people and you you
use that right um so that's kind of what
John's um what he's getting at here um
so the people were waiting expectantly
and were all wondering in their hearts
if John might possibly be the Messiah
John answered them all I baptize you
with water but one who is more powerful
than I will come the straps of who s
candal I am not worthy to untie he will
baptize you with the Holy Spirit and
fire his winnowing Fork is in his hand
to clear his threshing floor and to
gather the wheat into his barn but he
will burn up the chaff with unquenchable
fire and with many other words John
exhorted the people and proclaimed the
good news to
them so you can see it's a
very intense it's not you know he is
born yay um it's it's a different vibe
so two weeks ago I mentioned um really
wrestling with sort of the notion of
like the second coming of Jesus when
that kind of featured prominently in the
reading and uh especially during all my
kind of deconstruction question asking
wrestling with theology years um at
least when that was in particularly
intense I think to some degree we're
always you know wrestling with what we
believe but that was like 15 years ago
or so for me was that was like fullon
and uh
that and it's sort of similar this would
be another um kind of thing I wrestled
with in the scriptures was this language
of you know hell and uh fire and
judgment and and all of those kind of
themes you know in the scriptures and so
uh this passage of course is like even
though it's a little bit cryptic but you
could probably pick up on the fact that
it's sort of there you know and uh it's
so in that sense it's a really good
example you got verse n with its image
of the the bad trees bearing bad fruit
and then they're thrown into the
fire or uh there's verse 17 with its um
image of the the wheat and the
chaff and I'll be sticking that metaphor
for the sake of kind of clarity um
tonight and uh right when you harvest
like what's that getting at when you
harvest wheat there is the um kind of
the the grain right which is like the
good stuff that the stuff that's sort of
lifegiving and you know turned into
bread and all that and then you have um
sort of everything else um you got the
the stock and the stems and the um the
husk and then you got this chaff this
sort of light fluffy stuff and uh but
it's all sort of the useless you know
worthless kind of aspects of the the
whole stock of wheat so um in the
ancient world you kind of had to you
know separate this out today this is
like a weird metaphor for us we don't
you know we're not an agrarian society
and such but for them they would have
all you know known what he was talking
about and um so what's kind of going on
here here well um in essence I think
kind of in the past what I was
doing was reading my own kind of
doctrine of Hell understood as Eternal
conscious torment I was kind of reading
that you know into um this
text and uh like so for example I took
the you know the
metaphor of um the the kind of wheat in
the chap to be like two types of
people right so you've got the kind of
um the wheat
people and uh they are um you know the
the kind of the this the saved ones and
then you have the chaff and they're like
the the Damned you know so you've got
kind of the the wheat as these kind of
the true you know the True Believers um
the good people the righteous the
Christians the you know something along
those lines
and then the chaff sort of it depends
upon people's sort of denomination and
Christian you know Theology of exactly
how you kind of slice up the world here
in the sense of for some Churches you
know it's like very narrow you know like
if you're not a part of our
denomination then you are the chaff you
know there's kind of that and then you
have a kind of
broader uh sort of if you're well if
you're a Christian you know well then
you're part of the wheat but then
everyone else you know sort of all the
other non-believers atheists um other
people people of other religions you
know that's kind of how it gets um kind
of spliced up which you know kind of
know though in that sense no matter how
you slice it we're still talking about
like
billions upon billions of people down
through
history which is you know fairly
disturbing which is why I was wrestling
with this all you know in my
deconstruction days like uh how do I
Square this God who is is love with
billions you know suffering and eternal
conscious
torment and
um so so and so to just to clarify too
you can see where like the wheat becomes
well it says you know they're gathered
into barns right which I took as kind of
metaphor for heaven and then you've got
or the um the chaff of course is burned
with that unquenchable fire so then I
kind of read in like oh okay I get it
you know they're um they're they're
burning in you know in hell and at least
Le that's how i' have read this text 15
years ago but if you've um if you've
attended the table for any length of
time um You probably started to you know
tune in to well you know how I kind of
read texts like this um following
Christians um lots of them like St Isaac
the Syrian uh Gregory vanissa uh even CS
Lewis um George McDonald who I'll quote
shortly uh I read this really
differently now and I think the the
shifts for those unfamiliar that the two
shifts that I've kind of made um
following those folks and their thinking
was um a to sort of understand hell as
more like
Purgatory more like a um a kind of
process a place of
purification and uh the kind of the the
healing and restoration of the Soul as
opposed to a final
stop um which would be like Eternal
conscious torment right um I'm thinking
of um passages like in Romans really
Romans 9111 I think get it this um or
there's the phrase you know um as in
Adam all
die so in Christ all shall be made
alive um or you have Colossians 1 how um
through Christ he's reconciling not even
just all people but actually all things
right that the whole idea of of even
Romans 8 is All Creations groaning not
just people you know or Humanity but
it's like all creation just groaning
waiting longing for the day of its
Redemption and so the question becomes
well how do you square passages like
that um with hell talk you know what I
mean so that that's how these
theologians down to the centuries have
done it is said ah uh it must be that
hell is not actually the final
um word on these folks but it's it's a a
kind of temporary place uh before the
soul kind of goes on um so there's sort
of that so that' be one shift and then
kind of tied into that would be um in
essence it's about hell's about
restorative justice as opposed to
retributive
Justice um so it's it's yeah it's about
that Shalom that wholeness as opposed to
kind of being a form of payback you know
so okay okay so that changes right that
influences how we interpret and read a
text like this and so rather than saying
oh okay I get it I get this passage I
get look through there are two types of
people and some are wheat and some are
chaff uh now I would read it differently
uh and this really holds with my
experience of people in general um
knowing folks of other religious
Traditions knowing Christians in every
kind of wing of the church and my own
experience of even self um now I would
say this I think we all contain within
us
both wheat and
chaff that's how I read this text so as
opposed to two kinds of people you know
and there's the good people and then we
all get to be here and we're all the
wheat people and boy do we feel good
about ourselves you know we're like yep
we got it right they all got it wrong
and they're foolish you know no instead
it becomes uh so in other words instead
of this passage sort of flying over our
heads so to speak like um not in a sense
of not understanding but I guess in the
sense of sort of like sidest stepping
like oh this isn't talking about me you
know I'm saved or whatever uh no all of
a sudden now it actually does speak to
us
um this is uh like we might say in
essence then um we all have within
us that aspect of ourselves that is the
wheat um it it
is um to use the language of the book of
Romans it's it's that those parts of us
that have been Sanctified and healed and
made whole you might even say with a
doctrine of creation that there is a
Divine goodness within us just by virtue
of us existing it's like we're we're
God's Offspring we're children of God
you know we're from not even just in a
sort of purely metaphorical sense but
like in some kind of literal sense we we
come from God so right there is a
certain Divine goodness
um within us kind of at our core I would
say however at the same time there are
those other uh parts of ourselves uh you
know the the kind of unredeemed the
unhealed the unsubmitted aspects of our
lives and so in essence the decision to
follow Jesus to even kind of participate
in the life of the church um is not
about joining a kind of excl exclusive
club right where again like I said we
all kind of sit around like oh isn't it
nice to be wheat you know um but
actually it's it's a little bit more
like joining a
gym where we commit to um bring our life
more and more and more into alignment
with the person and work of Jesus Christ
right where through our own energy and
the Very Grace and goodness of God
working in Us by the spirit what what
happens the chaff of our
life is burned
away the wonderful Christian novelist
and writer George McDonald he put it
this way when we say by the way I should
give a little background on him he was a
Scottish preacher he only preached for
two years though because he preached
sermons like this and they ran him out
of town so um but he he put it this way
this is really profound he said when we
say that God is love do we teach people
that their fear of him is groundless no
as much as they fear will come upon them
possibly far more the Wrath will consume
what they call themselves so that the
selves God made shall appear oh God I
that is fantastic right in essence like
it's pretty intense because it's like oh
yeah no it's G to burn you know like in
essence not to what degree that's
literal or I don't you know what I mean
like is there fire in I don't know like
whatever the elements would be to do
that but the idea right is um that these
kind of who we think we are you know all
this this kind of falseness about us
like well that's who I am that's who I
am you know and and all of the sudden we
like life and following Christ is this
process of that just burning
away just burning
away I mean and is this not life it's
like hard as hell you know what I mean
and it's God it's a purifying
fire it's a purifying fire fire it is I
mean I know y'all stories dear lord it's
a lot it's it's hard and and this is why
right we Retreat we Retreat we're like h
no more no more not interested no more
no more growing for
me ah but God in his goodness just the
spirit in her goodness just keeps saying
come on come on come on come on come on
a writer poet musician Jason Upton um
has these pinned these words he said in
the silence you are
speaking in the quiet I can feel the
fire and it's burning burning deeply
burning all it is that you
desire you see the chaff of my life your
life too must be
burned
away Christianity living the Christian
Life it's more like going to the gym
it's more like Divine therapy ever been
to therapy know it's
hard it's healing it's
good but oh man it's hard why because
it's there that we face all of the crap
we've been spending our whole lives
avoiding you know running away like I
don't want to deal with that I don't
want to look at that I don't want to
acknowledge that feels like a
burning to say like yeah this this is
the truth this is what I've done this is
what I've experienced this is what I've
been through this is my own invitation
to growth you know oh
hurts we want to go back to being
comfortable we like a
caterpillar just want to go back to my
cocoon you know we like a baby with a
mess in our diaper and God's trying to
clean us up we're like no oh you know
you ever had the trying to change a DI
it's like ridiculous the kids you know
like 2 years old and just a it's and it
stinks I mean it's awful you know but
they're just like fighting you kicking
you're like
no that's us you
[Laughter]
know but we're just comfortable you know
we're comfortable with the way we've
always
been but in the silence you're speaking
in the quiet I can feel the fire and
it's burning it's burning deeply
burning all it is that you
desire so I want to ask rhetorically you
don't have to answer what's the chaff of
your life that's burning right
now if you're not sure you can just ask
where am I
suffering where am I
suffering and and what's behind that
you know in essence like what's the
what's the
stories what's the
fears what's the pain what's the ideas
what what are the beliefs the
expectations the
identities false identities but the
identities I've kind of wrapped around
myself and I'm like presenting to the
world this is who I you know and it's
just not true what what are the what are
the um
yeah what what's the the not just
identities but this the sense of um the
areas where we're just kind of it's
almost like we're addicted to to being a
certain way or to certain
things and and it's just beginning to
um kind of fall away or at least we're
being invited to let it go and I guess
the question would be are we open you
know to that
process am I open to the burning of the
chaff because see in the life to
come um I don't know exactly how like
Free Will and God's calling and you know
how all that plays out that
ultimately um the healing and
restoration of all things and all people
will happen I I don't know exactly how I
mean it's a little complicated I think
on the one hand we're kind of well I
could just resist God God you know um
but is that free is that freedom for
like the the addict you know to keep
using they're like it's I'm free I'm
free to do this you know it's like is
that freedom I know you know so there's
complicated theology there so I don't
know about the life to come exactly how
that plays out um what I do know is
right now we for sure have a choice you
know we have some agency you
know and uh the question is I guess we
be open to that
burning Richard Roar reflecting on this
uh John the Baptist in this very passage
writes these words he says John the
Baptist spirituality is brilliantly a
spirituality of
descent not asent John says of Jesus he
must grow bigger I must grow
smaller there's got to be such I love
this word
emptiness in our own lives or we cannot
Point Beyond ourselves to Jesus John did
such emptiness doesn't just fall into
our laps such humility does not just
happen it is surely the end product of a
thousand letting goes and a thousand
acts of
devotion I love that a thousand letting
goes that feels like my
life I even you know I I think of
death I think it's probably like the
less of this process you have
engaged my hunches the harder that
is because you just spent your life like
you know what I mean clinging
holding control you know what I mean
you've spent your and then all of a
sudden it's
like
no you know like I don't mean to get too
morbid with you or too intense but
there's something to that and so it's
almost like it is a kind of death you
know I mean I think of even Jesus words
about that kind of invitation to to die
die you know that you might live there's
a there is a kind of a death of sorts
but again it's it's a kind of death
that's leading to Life as we just keep
letting go
surrendering letting go of my false
sense of self letting go of my agenda
letting go of my identity letting go of
how I want things to be a thousand
10,000 letting goes it's interesting
where John the Baptist goes with this
chaff talk um he gets very practical you
might have caught that in the past
passage uh to read this section again he
says of the people what should we do
then the crowd asked John answered
anyone who has two shirts should share
right you can see the letting go gester
there should share with the one who has
none anyone who has food should do the
same even Tax Collectors came teacher
they asked what should we do don't
collect any more than you're required to
we told them and some soldiers what
should we do don't extort money don't
accuse people falsely be content with
your pay see we often think of I think
spirituality Christianity
you know religion this is sort of Airy
Fairy stuff you know it's ideas and its
doctrines and its kind of abstractions
and and all that uh things of the spirit
you know it's all invisible but I think
actually the truth is that spirituality
is it is the single most hard noosed
practical thing in the world like when
done rightly it it kind of touches down
in our life
in the most tangible of ways it's about
how we use power it's about how we
relate to others it's about how we spend
our money it is earthy and practical and
tangible it's about clothes and food and
bodies and sharing and
relating so in closing where I think
this at least where I hope this
perspective can be really help ful is it
can
reframe the the burning in our lives as
actually pointing to something
incredibly
transformative and
Powerful like to kind of come back to
the gym metaphor uh there's uh I know
lots of I know I'm thinking of like uh a
PhD who's has talked about like um
working out weightlifting and stuff like
that and and uh he named one of the in
their studies one of the key things that
you know someone who can kind of stick
to a workout program versus those who
like ditch you know um is often he says
the
reframing of kind of the pain and the
struggle and the oh this hurts um as
actually being the moment where you
realize it's
working right in essence because this is
all our struggle you start to want to
work out until it hurts you know I me
and then it's sort of like okay I'm out
of this you know let's some cycling
until so we're like laboring up a hill
and it's like oh my
gosh oh but if you can reframe it and
realize like all of your cycling was
leading you to that very moment like
this is where Fitness is going to be
able to happen you know me if you're a
lifting weights we want to give up right
when it's like okay now it's burning
let's put these things down it's like no
no no no that's like you you got all you
did everything to get you to that moment
this is not the time to to escape this
is the moment to press in like this is
this is the thing this is when you it's
working you know so how does that apply
like right can you see where in our own
lives it's a precisely the moment where
I'm out out out out out this is hurting
like think of it like for example
relationally you know I mean was like in
a a struggle with someone and just like
checking out I don't got time or energy
for this you know um and I get there's
times where there's like abuse or
something I'm not talking about those
I'm talking about normal
relational
stuff and can you see where it's like
that's precisely when the growth is
happening growing when it's all easy
like we just love each other it's great
you know okay well it's I'm glad you're
enjoying it but there's no growth there
you know what I mean um or spiritual
practices
same uh sitting in silence it's hard you
know just take like 20 minutes and just
sit there's going to be a moment where
you're just like I just want to get up I
need to do something this is I'm getting
antsy I'm getting I don't like this you
know and of course like that's the
point that's what it's showing you
that's the learning that's that that
antsiness that need to I got to change
got to do something gotta you know the
anxiety
that yeah so I think it's the
same um in our spiritual life and so my
hope is that understanding this we can
um begin to reframe begin to kind of
relax into the discomfort at times relax
knowing
hey that's a sign of the Holy Spirit at
work in you it's a sign of the spirit's
activity it is the chaff of your life
burning away friends this Advent season
may we say yes to that
burning in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit
amen so on the night uh Jesus was
betrayed he had one final meal with his
disciples at that meal he held up a loaf
of bread and then he broke it he said
this is my body it's broken for you then
he held up a cup of wine he said this is
my blood it's shed for you you whenever
you eat this bread whenever you drink
this cup remember
me so as we come to the table of the
Lord tonight as we take in the body of
Christ in the bread the blood of Christ
in the wine may we be open to all that
God wants to do open to that heal and
restorative
purifying
process so uh we'll go just Front Row
first um and practice an open table
so um everyone here is welcome to
participate remember the red is wine
white is grape juice and uh finally you
can just partake Whenever However you'd
like some folks like to kneel up here in
front some like to return to their seats
um but no one will lead you through the
exact moment of partaking so you can do
that as you feel that so this is the
table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who feel
like you
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
for
[Music]
we bring the of our hands and now lay it
down lay it in your
feet what we've done what we built what
we've
broken lay it down lay it at your
[Music]
feet you
hold it
all Jesus you
hold it all
[Music]
wor hurs we head weaken
body lay it down lay it at your
feet where we've used where we' lost
what we've
wasted lay it
down your
feet you hold
it Jesus you hold it
oh you
hold Lord Jesus
[Music]
you all our dreams all our plans our
Ambitions lay it down lay it at your
feet and even if nothing comes
to lay it down lay it at your
feet lay it
[Music]
down your
thank you all so much for joining us
tonight um if you're new we'd love for
you to scan the QR code on the screen or
as you head out um just so we can say
thanks for being here answer any
questions you might have about what an
lgbtq affirming Church looks like we're
so happy to have you here um for meetups
we could all use more support and
connection um at the table we do that
through meetups you can also scan that
QR code to find one that works for you
generosity is a huge part of a life of
adoration and worship if the table uh if
you call the table your home um and you
would like to give you can scan the QR
code or head to the table tx.org
[Music]
now I'm going to send you into your week
with a blessing um you can hold your
hands open um or just open your hearts
um to these words
you are a child of
God you are a child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst day so as you
go into your week ahead with its yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are loved you are
worthy and you are accepted just as you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come into contact with be
blessed and have a wonderful week we'll
see you next week for Christmas Eve
service
all our dreams all our plans our
Ambitions lay it down lay it
your and even nothing comes
to lay it down lay it your
feet lay it down l